hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus crossing
invitational it's anish givery versus
yaniponishi and
this is the second game of the second
match so the first four games of the
first match ended in a draw ended the
first game ended in a draw here in the
second match where nepo had the white
pieces
it was a it was a pretty feisty sicilian
and
now where gary has the white pieces we
will again have the sicilian so a bit of
a
sicilian contest between the two of them
and this is a pretty crazy game so
without further ado let's check it out
uh giri opens
with e4 and as we said dion replies with
c5 we have the sicilian defense
uh knight to f3 e6 and now d4
striking in the center we have captures
on d4 knight
captures and the knight to c6 now uh we
have knights the c3 and the queen to c7
now going for the basical variation of
the timon of we have bishop to e3
and now a6 and this position has been
reached thousands of times
with moves like for example queen d2 or
bishop to d3 there are over
two 2 500 top tier games in the database
featuring just
those moves but there are many other
moves as well but the move gear he
chooses is
a very very rare one he plays g4 here
and it's not a new move but it's an
extremely rare move only only a handful
of games featuring this move
and now he asks sian do you know how to
deal with this uh and okay young
continues with
h6 there is a a few games where b5 was
played but the movie on plays h6 has
never been played before
asto already has a move seven we have a
completely new game
so gary continues uh marching those
pawns forward on the king side he wants
to play g5
uh and knight to f6 now we have knight
captures on c6
b captures on c6 now setting up for this
very nice central thrust with d5
and the queen to f3 the queen will also
support d5 from here and the white
is planning to castle queen side so d5
why not if white allows it
uh and g5 now attacking that knight we
have captures captures and
now of course captures we have queen
captures on h1
and knight the g for putting pressure on
anish's knight
bishop here on e3 bishop back to d2 not
allowing this straight knight for bishop
and now
just bishop to b7 yep we're very happy
with his king at the center of the board
he says you you don't really have
anything here
uh and now queen to h3 reactivating the
queen which tempo as the knight is now
under attack we have knights to e5 by
nipple
and queen side castles by geary uh we
have d4
not worried about his king still being
in the center of the board he attacks
that knight
pushes it back knights to b1 knight can
also come to a4 also a very nice square
but uh giri decides to go to b1
and now c5 yeah now wants to play c4 or
get
the rook into the game maybe maybe even
c3 at some point so
he likes his attacking chances but here
geary plays
f4 puts pressure on the knight here and
now the knight needs to move so here
and the problem is the knight needs to
move to g6 however here jan played
knight to c6 and this is already a
pretty bad move and the gui takes
advantage of this move uh in uh well
in a very nice way so feel free to pause
the video here and try to take advantage
of
black's uh well misplaced knight while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
realizing why the knight had to come to
g6 and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
that it's g6 that's the stuff uh the
knight had to be there
to prevent the spawn push and now with
g6 we are weakening the e6 square and
this uh
if this opens up then uh black's
position will be just ruined so here
uh you don't really have much option you
have to do what nipple did
castle's queen side and now geary
captures on f7
we have queen captures on f7 and now
bishop to c for piling up on that e6
pawn
and there's no good way to defend it if
you try to defend it with some like rook
to e8 then
f5 comes and you now realize that
everything is pinned this is pinned and
this is pin so you cannot capture
because bishop captures queen
and here white would just get any not
that
uh white would just get an extremely
strong pass pawn on e6
uh so instead after bishop to c4 jan
just you know steps back with the king
king to b8
and now of course geary grabs that pawn
bishop captures on e6 and in doing so
creates a very very strong past e pawn
uh and it's uh well
it's gonna be very hard to stop it the
f4 pawn also very nicely defended by the
bishop so
uh giri has everything covered so queen
to c7
getting the queen out of harm's way and
now bishop back to c4
now we have king to a7 for a little bit
more safety
and now knight to a3 the knight is not
coming to c4 bishop to b3 knight c4 is
coming
but maybe in some weird cases if this
pawn disappears ideas like knight b5
also become possible
so knight to b4 putting pressure on
white's position hoping that
maybe uh maybe gary would be interested
in giving up this bishop but of course
not
uh so rook to e1 getting ready to push
this past pawn
and bishop to e7 now uh jan needs to
activate the dark square bishop somehow
king to b1 not allowing any knight jumps
to come with the check so king is
very safe here on b1 and rook the e8
uh we have e5 by giri and now bishop to
d8 so shifting the
bishop to d8 from f8 and now the rook is
at least doing something you
you can't push for a moment because the
e5 pawn falls
so here bishop back to b3 freeing up the
c4 square for white's knight and
now finally as uh nippo created the
setup for it
g5 weakens the e5 pawn as the f4 pawn is
under attack and here of course if you
capture then rook characters here
uh maybe it's possible to defend this if
rook captures queen captures
the problem is this knight comes to c4
and it's again a very very nice position
for white
uh heart uh very hard to play this for
black at some point white will have to
play a three kick away this night just
to create some breeding room for the
king
but for the moment the black has no way
of taking advantage of this so instead
after g5
immediately knights the c4 there's
always time to do that and now of course
f5 is also the thread because now the e5
pawn is defended twice
so here g captures on f4 bishop captures
on f4 and now
knight to d5 just uh trying to
centralize that knight also the bishop
is now under attack but giver he once
again just moves it back
bishop to d2 d51 nicely defended this
knight cannot be moved from here you
don't have the b
pawn so queen to g7 now
and here comes knight to d6 by geary
attacking the
rook attacking the bishop on b7 and not
a lot to do here so
rook the h8 moving the rook with tempo
the queen is under attack but now queen
to e6 and again
there's a double attack on the knight
here the bishop is under attack
everything
is very nicely placed for white and it's
hard to find a move for nipple
uh there uh well you you probably have
to move the knight something like knight
to b6 then gary would continue with a4
a5 he he wants to move his a pawn either
way so it's going to be
uh you know a multi multi-purpose move
uh but here nipple played
bishop to h4 he put pressure on the rook
on e1 but now it uh
doesn't work here gary played rook to c1
and there there's even a forcing line
that's kind of much better but it
requires too much calculating and they
were both very low on time
i will show it because it's a lot of fun
but starts with knight captures on b7
point is you give up the rook bishop
captures on e1 now you go knight
captures on c5 you threaten the a6 pawn
and there's no good move here if you tr
if black tries to defend it then you
just pick up the bishop here you're up
up material and you keep the attack and
if black tries to go for everything with
capturing the piece
then you go queen captures on a6 with
check king b8
now queen b5 check king a7 and you
create
a breeding square for the king and now
you just have a
winning advantage there is no uh there's
no uh way to play this even though black
is up material
uh it it's not going to do him all that
much because the knight is being
threatened here for example
rook to the eighth defending the knight
you can just pick it up
and now go after that rook sound like
queen a6 check king b8 queen b6 check
and now
wherever the king goes you're just going
to give a check pick up the rook and
then you're going to be
up too much material for example king b8
queen captures here
and you're up three pawns of course
completely winning
but it requires a lot of calculating
uh and that requires time of course so
instead rook back to c1 there is no rush
here
and now knight to c7 nepal brings the
knight
back now attacking the white queen queen
back to c4
and now queen captures an e5 but
uh it it doesn't help knights to f7
attacking the rook and the queen with
queen to h2
uh and now comes uh queen captures and
c5 with check you could capture the rook
but
there's no rush just queen captures on
c5 with check eliminate all of black's
counterplay
uh king to b8 and now even queen
captures on d4
not going for the rook there's always
time to capture it it's not really doing
anything
and we're defending the bishop here so
rook the fate by nipple
and now queen to f4 with a double attack
on the queen and putting pressure on the
knight here
so here bishop to g3 was played but now
giri just trades captures captures and
here queen to b4
and he was in this position on mu 41
that uh ianni pony should resign the
game
and after five draws we have the first
decisive game which goes to anish giri
with the white pieces and now
uh every uh you know every a little bit
of pressure is on nipple because now he
has two games to bounce back and
you know either try and just equalize
the four star breaks or even win two
games in a row
and then take it all so we'll see what
what's going to happen but
uh uh now i think uh things are going to
get
pretty wild as they've played the
sicilian uh both games on the second day
and i think the trend might continue so
you know i think we're in for in for a
treat uh here we resign because
uh well the knight is defended the rook
is hanging here and that there is no
good move here well if you try to move
the rook rook ca just knight d6
now attacks the for example the bishop
threatening checkmate the rook is under
attack and
it doesn't matter what you do you're
just going to lose if queen f3 guarding
checkmate
you just pick up the rook and after
captures you're now up too much material
uh there's there's no even point in in
trying to play this
so after queen before uh uh nipple
resigned and
uh the first victory of the finals of
the magnus cross and invitational goes
to anish
giri uh so yeah that's the game uh hope
you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank george pick uh
george pick uh steven scandal
uh alex nokia and uh chair for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the magnus invitational
checking up on your uh wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day